okay we're back in the albino assassin
has rejoined this I think you got to
take that Roger that's a pretty [ __ ]
awesome nickname albino us yeah you
should you should take it you should use
it as a handle tweet it succeed in an
hour
have goose avert tattooed on your back
[Music]
Roger when you defend Edward Snowden's
leaking of classified information the
same way you defend Julian Assange and
Lucifer what do you think about it no I
probably wouldn't I think the
situation's are somewhat different but I
also continue to reject the idea that
Assange is an asset of the Russians I
think he's an opponent of the deep state
all my liberal friends loved him when he
was leaking on george w bush what do you
think about that general i was pretty
consistent in my view about Assange okay
I just liked him then I just like him
now and he may or may not be a winning
agent of the Russian Federation but he
is an agent of the Russian Federation he
seems to have changed well I think at
the beginning to be a little bit
different but it only seems to be
America oh that he that he finds [ __ ] on
like we're the only country in the world
that has [ __ ] I could be found out I
mean there are a lot of other societies
out there that really do have secrets
yeah very harmful and he continues to
push only American secrets out the door
and what do you think I'd be defending
Trump now I mean they WikiLeaks is
actually going out of its way to defend
the Trump administration's you check
their Twitter feed they're spending a
lot of time doing that but why why do we
learn today that the CIA has malware
that can mimic transmissions from the
Russians why would we need such a thing
oh I can give you lots of reasons why
I'm yeah I'm sure you could Roger you
guys did a bang-up job in the Iraq war
probably dark bleep to then go to this
natural capability that you would expect
an espionage agency and a half and
immediately jump over here and said they
used it to destabilize the American
democracy so what do you think should
happen with Snowden he should continue
to live in Moscow exactly okay and
okay well we'll leave it there Rick do
you think that Mike Pence can continue
to help Trump's wage of Angelica 'ls in
his favor look I think the biggest thing
that that Donald Trump has done to help
with with religious voters evangelicals
is the the appointment of Neil gorgeous
to the Supreme Court I mean that right
that was the reason that many folks
lined up behind Donald Trump why he did
as well as any Republican with
evangelical community because they knew
his Supreme Court seat was open they
wanted someone who was going to be like
Antonin Scalia Trump promised he would
do that and he delivered I don't think
actually Mike Pence has to do a lot to
to rally evangelicals where I think
they're very happy with what what the
biggest issue on their plate and if
Trump would by some crazy quirk wind up
not being president because of
impeachment or something
I hear liberals some saying what Mike
Pence would be worse and this infuriates
me
Mike time would not be worse we know who
Mike Pence is he's a down the line you
know he would be somewhat similar to a
rebellion like North Korea or something
you have to worry about crazy war
exactly like if you were president Rick
I wouldn't go to bed every night nervous
I mean I do you do that you ever say
anything like that seriously I mean I
are in one's dangerously unstable raises
concern about which one I do okay I mean
there's policy and this personality and
and it's a personality part that worries
me way more I hear I hear that I mean
that when you think about what's
happened with the Pentagon or who he's
the kind of forces at the NSC you know
they are they're people who you know
should worry all of us about stability
in the global order but you know I just
I I think that you know Mike Pence's no
walk in the park either no he's not but
but I'm glad we agree that he is
preferable to dot anyone is Donald Trump
is the worst person in America like what
is that
not even play there's other people okay
all right did anyone hear that that it
came out that during the inauguration
George Bush what was over whispered
after Trump's speech that was some weird
[ __ ] and if you keep this painting he
doesn't have much room Tom liked him so
much honestly I've been consistent on
that too though all right I like the men
I like I'm not oh yeah look I mean
Donald Trump is not your typical
Republican that was certainly not a
typical Republican inauguration address
it refuted a lot of the Bush Doctrine it
was art and I'm sure he was offended
it had three different Appeals for
racial unity which everybody seemed to
ignore but it was right there you make
sure you yes you see I don't have my
copy on me but it's really say they said
racially they're there I was sitting 10
feet away they're there because you're
very close to the president right I mean
a presidency that is run by Breitbart
news I mean I mean I mean let's think
about this we have a presidency that is
being run by Breitbart news our
immigration policy on time no I suppose
to the white nationalism to supremacist
who run Breitbart news we have all that
what do you all right this is not
alternative liquor this is not the left
guard named fire I'm not gonna call her
the right brain fart use the term I'll
just say use the term pike do you think
that's right that's right
okay well let's weed it out later
builders it was important line in the
speech and the president said I pledge
allegiance to the American people that's
not common in the American tradition you
know I take an oath is to the
Constitution of the Alliance it's to the
process it words to the ideas of America
not not the blood and soil and that is
that is a clear distinction it's
different we'll see where it goes how
would you grade Trump as
commander-in-chief in light of the
recent uptick in civilian deaths in Iraq
and Syria yeah I would not be a harsh
judge because I was always complaining
with throughout of the Obama
administration being late light
under-resourced and over regular
he's pushed he's pushed decision-making
down into the forward area and I don't
know I really don't know it does cause
and effect between the decision-making
pattern and the effect all we've got is
a lot of indirect fire in a tough fight
in a heavily populated area right I mean
we're trying to dislodge ice right from
one city and it's taken months and
months and months so for the people who
say the Westboro Baptist Church is the
equivalent oh I'm more concerned about
after we win and we take Mosul and we
take Raqqa because if we kill our way
out of this we'd have been done a long
time ago exactly right
what does the panel think of the house
vote on Tuesday to roll back the FCC's
internet privacy protections right well
the crowd groan there yeah we don't have
a lot of intricate privacy protections
anyway but this was another giant blow
job to corporations yes Trump yes
oh you're against that I don't think we
should be we should be regulating the
net then we shouldn't be handing control
of the net the United Nations and it's
not what this was this was this was
saying corporations could take your
browsing history and now well against
that okay they do it now is what they do
it on Google and Facebook which are
voluntary you that you enter those on
your own well this is the in working you
in what other search engines what search
engines out there don't scream don't do
it it's not even a search so you say
it's voluntary but there isn't one that
doesn't do it so it's really not
voluntary is it we just say the bottom
line of this is like they're all
libertarian until it helps corporations
and then they're not libertarian at all
mister is your the theory is you're
going to stop the government from
to you I feel I've helped the
corporation this is a partisan vote
Republicans were all on one side of a
government one on your browser history I
mean who knows what guys you guys your
guys my clothes yeah come on you only
knew I only knew and now we all will how
we do yeah
erase quickly okay Nero well Obamacare
explode if Congress doesn't amend it
that's a great question now I mean
actually was illustrative of this whole
discussion we learned in this debacle of
the Republican effort to Rory the
Affordable Care Act is the Congressional
Budget Office did a determination and
actually said the the false out the
false stuff out there is that Obamacare
will die well it's been a death spiral
all of that is frankly BS there are
challenges they can be fixed and you
know what if Trump wants to deal with
Democrats to actually make progress
that's not going to happen oh it may not
feel like let's try and get let's not
tolerate your rid of covered with it but
they're but they're not even hiding the
fact that they are actively sabotaging
and then you've never had any Democrats
that's okay because they're against it
and it's not their philosophy but what
can Democrats do to combat that so that
they can't kill it well we did defeat
them last week and they defeated
themselves the problem turns out the
active cell yeah so here's the thing I
think the truth is that there are places
there are challenges but the law is
stable that is what the Congressional
Budget Office even shake your head Rick
but that is what is not I mean here's
the real or Nia is a perfect example of
a state with great insurance markets
where the priests have been low sure if
you support it it works yeah if you're a
let it work you let a function it works
well states like Kansas are trying to do
Medicaid expansions now because they
recognize the law is here to stay that's
what we should have people who are not
trying to sabotage coverage for people
who are their constituents but actually
try to make this law work and if they do
there is an opportunity to pursue a
little alternative viewpoint number one
this is
this is a bill that puts over 700
billion dollars if Democrats are healthy
Obama Obama care is seven hundred
billion dollars taken from huge huge
it's a huge amount of money you know we
are gonna learn from people who will not
miss it that's where the money comes
[Applause]
colors in here no it is redistrict it is
redistribution of wealth I I don't know
why Democrats just don't own this I know
you hate that but I don't think people
do it is redistribution of wealth it is
absolute laughing you're trapped make
sure they pour the huge redistribution
of wealth right and it's a system where
the government is controlling what
access you have to insurance everybody
not just the people who didn't have
insurance before
now there's real saying you can have set
forth a plan that very few businesses
but we're able to comply with the
exemption and so now everybody almost
everybody has to have plans that the
government says our best for you I'd
have to have coverages the government
you know we had a debate about essential
husband I give you a lot of chances I
talk about this yeah the reality is that
yes we dramatically expanded the number
of people insured all over half of which
through was through government programs
Medicaid Medicaid was the biggest part
of the expansion got come even Kansas
but now even can just voted for the
Medicaid expansion is going to spend or
not on whether with that one also not
remember a liberal state it's well
you're right because they want people
because it's free money
exactly yeah well your money dreams or
the hair or people's health repeal
you're not a good cause how we remade
that that if you take this money you
know you're going to get this you're
going to get free money from the federal
government if you lose pay care
apportionment and had a debate about
this and Republicans couldn't pass their
own bill because it had seventeen
percent approval whatever's right for
you don't you think should hate it
I couldn't pass this bill because they
didn't fundamentally change what was in
place right now the bottom line what had
to happen if they were going to change
this they needed to follow the path that
previous Republican Congress's who made
big entitlement reforms followed I was
involved in that bill as a 1996 welfare
bill and what we did is we eliminated
the federal entitlement we gave all the
money to the states and said states you
determine the policy that's best for you
you design your own Medicaid program you
design your own private sector markets
and you go out there and innovate and
every state will have the chance to do
that we'll find states to do it really
well
we'll find states that do it really
poorly and guess what states learn from
each other there's a lot more
experimentation there's a lot more
innovation there's a lot more freedom
and that's what works in America right
government control by the top-down does
not work okay and that's what Donald
Trump's rant ago the people who get
bladder cancer in the state that
experiments badly they just die yeah but
the people who get it in the state
that's good at it
the Marvel about healthcare this is
always about health insurance there's
everybody in America prior to Obamacare
was legally required if you went to a
hospital the hospital must treat you yes
the bottom line is that when the insurer
and you disagree with me and they
fact-checked you and we're wrong now
which is when you gave people insurance
under Medicaid actually emergency room
visits went up they didn't go down
people still use the hospital as the MRF
as their primary care for not having
insurance but people like you have
insurance and are okay with it I want to
have insurance but I don't want the
federal government dictating to me what
my insurance is I want markets to work
so people have freedom exactly freedom
thank you very much everybody I
appreciate you helping us out
[Applause]